Hallo Leute! Heute werden wir euch einige Vokabeln
rund um das Thema Kleidung vorstellen.
Oder wie man auch sagt: die Klamotten.
Wisst ihr, wie man die einzelnen Teile nennt?
Dann schaut mal her. Los geht's!
die Jacke, die Jacken
der Mantel, die Mäntel
die Regenjacke, die Regenjacken
die Jeansjacke, die Jeansjacken
die Cordjacke, die Cordjacken
die Mütze, die Mützen
der Hut, die Hüte
der Schal, die Schals
der Handschuh, die Handschuhe
der Stiefel, die Stiefel
die Sandale, die Sandalen
der Schuh, die Schuhe
die Socke, die Socken
die Hose, die Hosen
die Jogginghose, die Jogginghosen
das T-Shirt, die T-Shirts
das Hemd, die Hemden
das Jackett, die Jacketts
die Krawatte, die Krawatten
der Anzug, die Anzüge
die Strickjacke, die Strickjacken
der Pullover, die Pullover
der Kapuzenpullover, die Kapuzenpullover
eine Jacke, zwei Jacken
ein Mantel, zwei Mäntel
In dieser Episode kommen viele Vokabeln vor,
bei denen es nicht so einfach ist, zu wissen,
wie die Pluralform gebildet wird.
Probiert doch mal unsere App Seedlang aus.
Dort haben wir einen Pluraltrainer, mit dem ihr
die Pluralformen von vielen weiteren Nomen lernen könnt.
Nun zeigen wir euch noch einige Sätze,
die man nutzen kann, wenn man Kleidung beschreiben möchte.
Warum macht Mitch sich so schick?
Mmh, das steht dir gut, Mitch!
Du hast dein Shirt falsch rum an.
Mach doch mal die Jacke zu!
Das ist dir zu klein.
Das ist dir zu groß.
Das steht dir nicht so gut.
Die Farbe kann Mitch gut tragen.
Die Hose ist zu kurz.
Die Hose passt Mitch nicht.
Die Schuhe sind Mitch zu klein.
Die Jacke ist für den Frühling viel zu warm.
Die Farbe passt gut zu Mitchs Augenfarbe.
Die Farbe passt gut zu Mitchs Haarfarbe.
Mitch knöpft sich das Hemd zu.
Trägst du den Anzug ohne Krawatte?
Mitch bindet sich die Krawatte.
Mitch legt sich den Schal um.
Mitch zieht eine Mütze auf.
Oder zwei. Oder drei.
Mitch zieht die Jacke an.
Diese Schuhe sind unbequem.
Der Pullover kratzt.
Dieser Stoff ist schön weich.
Die Farbe ist zu grell.
Mitch krempelt sich die Arme (Ärmel) hoch.
Mitch trägt Socken in den Sandalen. Wie ein Deutscher!
Heute ist es ziemlich kalt draußen.
Mitch zieht sich lieber warm an.
So, das war's. Ich hoffe, ihr konntet heute
viele weitere Vokabeln rund um das Thema Kleidung lernen.
Und wenn ihr jetzt noch weiter
die Pluralformen trainieren wollt,
probiert mal unsere App Seedlang aus. Bis bald!
Mitch trägt Socken in den Sandalen. Wie ein Deutscher!